this is a production of Cornell
University so now you can see the
visuals very happy to have you with us
I'm doing the best I can
in trying to support I think all of us
here at Cornell that feel really
fortunate to be working in an
environment where where we can set aside
financial things at least temporarily
while many people are concerned about
those things that's a big burden that
many folks are facing so we certainly
have the want to serve the people that
have to be out there are out there
working and and this is our small way of
doing that so first let me just say
everybody's got to keep themselves and
the closest to them safe and if you're
working and deemed essential that you're
putting safety first and and Cornell has
done this in its exact extension
disaster Network there are updates at
this website that you can see the
address for right there Carl post this
this is where you're going to find a
sort of nice consolidation of best
management practices from horticultural
operations for the way you should be
doing things and thinking about things
especially from a legal perspective
right it's really important to
understand particularly if you're
working that they're still still are
legal aspects to what's allowed and and
the confusion that surrounds that this
is a good place for a centralized
resource and all of us are scrambling
for information I think this is a good
way maybe put it on your list to
something that you check every once in a
while if you're in a decision-making
position it also gives you good sort of
information to pass on to your customers
say listen here's where we're getting
from from some smart people who are
thinking about how to keep us safe now
of course the governor is actively
issuing guidance through the various
agencies and of course we received this
just the other day on the interim
guidance for horticulture that then
gives you as lawn & landscapers in the
grounds operation people who are in the
maintenance of plants to me if I look at
the first dot here you know production
movement maintenance ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I'd
say well your maintenance
right of plants now not necessarily a
greenhouse and nursery operations so
treat you know tree trimming crews you
know I'm not expecting to have many of
them on this call I'm a grass guy but if
you're here you know obviously you're
focusing on hazard and safety right now
right you're probably thinking about the
way you're going to work right the
placement and maintenance of sod the
placement and maintenance of sod well
what's odd is it something planted can I
keep working
can I keep applying there's a lot of
ambiguity in this there's a million
questions anybody could ask about what
can I do this and can I do that what I
want to say at this point is that really
is a very separate discussion from any
technical expertise I have or we even
have here in the turfgrass program I'd
encourage you to seek out resources and
I've been promoting this resource from
Penn State University Tom Ford Extension
one of the extension faculty there at
Penn State wrote this really wonderful
best management practices for the green
industry and to be honest this is most
applicable to the lawn and landscape
folks grounds maintenance folks as well
I feel strongly this is a good resource
for you to start with and then there's
probably more specific things you're
going to find later on that might work
in your operation right working in teams
versus cluster you know you know smaller
groups deploying them differently we're
hearing lots of different strategies
about how people are being creative
while they're trying to determine if
they can work and when they're gonna
work how they're gonna work and what
they're allowed to do so you're not
gonna have a hundred percent confidence
in anything you do right now but your
focus ought to be if you're gonna work
how do I keep them safe and then we'll
decide what we're going to do right and
if I can't keep you safe by doing it
like you know you can't be safe playing
basketball so you got to stop playing
basketball you can be quote-unquote safe
playing golf so how do you play golf
safely right so if you're gonna do
things how do you do them safely and
there's lots of questions until testing
becomes widespread how much we got to do
so be care
all right so today our goal is to help
you decide if you're going to work
what's important factors to consider if
your work is slow because you have less
people listen in New York City all a
bunch of cops didn't come in yesterday
right people are ill and they're told if
they're sick stay home
so you're gonna get your work slow too
and maybe stop at some point if people
say well listen this isn't essential
anymore
who knows particularly in the
metropolitan areas of the Northeast
particularly in our metropolitan ears
and now of course we're seeing this
happening down in New Orleans as well so
first what is my advice to you if you're
managing grass and your setting and
center everything else aside let's just
talk about managing the grass the first
thing you want to do is don't do any
harm right don't do anything now that
might harm beneficial insects if you see
a lot of flowers in the lawn and you
can't get it mode don't put anything on
that lawn just try to avoid early
intervention don't get out and run and
do the fertilizer don't don't do your
normal reflex just cause you've always
done it and I know this is got to be the
hardest pill for the lawn and landscape
business here because so much of your
income and revenue and economy and
success is your ability to apply things
and yet I can tell you there's reasons
to hold back on this right now there's
reasons to hold back on this right now
and then how do you make these strategic
reductions if you're going to hold back
and you want to talk to your customers
about this well what can you do it is
still maybe have some income if if
that's an issue but most importantly how
to manage growth I think we can start to
do things now that help us manage growth
should this be prolonged into June July
right so so there are really important
things we can think about right now that
are going to help us if we start
thinking about them right now so first
off where are we well no surprise we're
way ahead of where we normally would be
right if you look at the 50-year average
and as the earth is warming and we just
came through a mild winter right a top
ten mild winter another one you can see
that the growing season is progressing
and
cases look at the amount of southeastern
states in the United States progressing
20 days ahead of normal spring leafing
our right certainly the magnolias is
Jerry Giordano told us yesterday and our
conference call that forsythias
magnolias are blooming all over Chester
County so for sure down south you're
seeing a lot of this happening in the in
the landscape down there now as you get
further north and and and nearer bodies
of water you can find some places all of
a sudden you know along the lake in the
metropolitan area Rochester looks like
it's surging ahead a little bit but
let's soil temperature be your guide
this is a good time to learn how to use
data this is a good time to think about
the things you do a little bit
differently as you're avoiding that
reflex action what's some of the things
you can do with that action you want to
take look at data if you have to be out
if you're out supervising crews stick
the soil thermometer in the ground this
is going to be the governing body of how
things progress right keep getting
averages temperatures warmer and getting
that soil warmer is what's going to
drive this growing season and until that
happens to any great degree I think we
should be in a preparing communication
and minimal cleanup thing right now
before we go surging into doing
everything really rapidly now water
right right now right now as we sit here
in the March 19th the 25th window we're
ahead in almost all cases particularly
in the Northeast you gotta go into the
to the DC area down into Virginia to
start to get any dry soil dry conditions
where we haven't had rainfall right so
so so moisture is good and and if you
look at you know we're gonna talk every
week if if you look at what's coming
next week we're gonna be good for a few
days looks like a lot of rain coming
through the Midwest our Midwestern
colleagues are getting really pounded in
the next couple of days and a lot of
that's gonna make it to the Northeast
well first and foremost the questions
everybody's got to be asking us we'll
listen I mow grass for a living what
about that well if you mow grass for a
living
you're in a tight spot
right because normally right it's it's
people like their lawns between two to
three inches which guarantees you if you
look at this chart that they'll chrysler
develop pretty easy to develop on your
own anywhere you know that you're
getting about an inch of growth a week
and that's sort of average you know
sometimes you get more sometimes you get
less i can tell you in a few weeks when
the soils get to fifty five degrees and
the air temperatures start to average 50
degrees for more than five days you're
gonna grow more than an inch a week in
the spring time you're gonna see greater
growth in the spring time but right now
right now where we sit throughout much
of the northeast we could let our grass
go to four and a half inches hmm could
be crazy
you should mow less if you have slowed
and stopped crews the way to mow less is
to raise that high to cut raise that
high to cut if you can get it up to four
inches that means you can let it go to
six I know I can see everybody's eyes
rolling oh my gosh Frank six inches
who's gonna tolerate that well I don't
think we know what people are gonna
tolerate to be honest with you I think
we're in ground we've never been before
I don't know what people are gonna
tolerate but I can tell you this is what
the science says if you're told you
gotta mow less the first thing you got
to do is raise the mow night get out
there you want to clean up you're gonna
work you want to keep you guys busy you
keep them safe clean up don't roast rush
the most are checking your growth and by
all means raise the high to cut now a
much more in-depth handling of this for
the lawn or landscape people versus
everybody else right because you're out
and about in society you're not working
in a confined golf course you're not
working on a confined sports field
you're out and about in society right so
first off if you're out thinking about
fertilizing right most of New York State
I ain't all of not all in New York stays
there's not before April 1st right so
we'll check your laws we got to
Wednesday of next week so if you're
running around spread and stuff
including weed and feed you want to make
sure you're consistent with your
regulation now remember the soil is
operating no matter what's happening
right the natural world goes on no
matter how our lives are sheltered
and it will release nitrogen naturally
as temperature goes and and the roots
have probably been growing all winter if
the ground didn't freeze up to any great
degree those roots are pushing what
we're talking about is top growth and
what we are going to see is that at some
point the soils are still going to be
cool but the air temperature is going to
be warmer and the nutrients aren't going
to be moving from the soil into the
grasses and they're going to look
off-color and that's our reflex to
fertilize I'm telling you if you just
wait for the soil to continue to warm it
will catch up and then the lawns will
green up naturally that is going to be
governed by soil temperature so our
recommendations is to avoid any large
applications of nitrogen and laughs as
the lawn is very fit right large greater
than three three tenths of a pound
actual em four thousand I would avoid
any large application why stimulate
growth
if mowing might get tricky later on we
know we're in a time where cool season
grasses will surge their growth anyway
at this time right let's we there's no
necessary need right now for
fertilization now if you have a thin
long like the mole that ravaged lawn and
you know behind me then feeding is the
move here seeding can be the move here
all right what about weeds diseases and
insects right crabgrass red thread white
grubs very much like I talked to the
sports guys and the golf guys right this
is a good time to go out and identify
weeds right there seems to be we're
still pretty early if you look at all
our broadleaf weed control models on our
forecast website you will see that we're
still very early for the applications
even for the ester we're just creeping
into the you know Central Jersey parts
right into the metro area for broadly if
we control with the Esther formulation
and if you have winter annuals that are
flowering like this one I took that a
couple took this picture a couple weeks
ago in Brooklyn when I was visiting
chick weed and flower the winter annuals
and flower don't bother applying a
product to these because these are going
to wane anyway as winter annuals
Bank is already contributed to right so
so no rush on the weed control and and
when you're considering weeds now first
get them identified make sure you know
what you got before you go start
deploying control measures and when it
comes to crabgrass you know this is
pretty straightforward the earlier you
go out with these products the earlier
they're gonna wear out now you might say
well I can go back and make a second
application
well you certainly could do that if
you're thinking about well I want to get
out now because they may not be able to
get out later I want to get out now
because the customers paying me and I
want to you know deliver the service
just know that going out early means you
know you come June right it's gonna be a
tricky ordeal so this could be a time in
some places to consider well where do I
need you where do I not need it again
trying to avoid the reflex action that
you may or may not need moving forward
but you get on some of these products
pretty long efficacy and this is found
in our Cornell guidelines for pest
management in turf commercial turf and
again Carl's gonna have all these links
all right
grub ID you know not a good time now to
do any curative control and you're still
early to get your preventative staff you
got time you got time for this I
wouldn't rush out to go do it putting it
down into these conditions particularly
if you got flowers in the lawns puts the
pollinators at risk that's not the
optics we need as an industry right now
so go out and take a look at your grubs
Kyle whippings like Jenny gone.if and in
the weed diagnostic thing in advance
here that I showed you and now hi-oh
wiki's work here with the grub ID you're
probably going to see grubs that look a
lot like the one down in here larger
size second third instar very tough to
kill with insecticides keep an eye on
them and also contributing to the
problem that you see behind me as well
all right well this has been a big topic
recently we've heard a lot from our
extension faculty in our in our regions
that that people are coming out and
seeing mold damage everywhere that Lee
at the bottom is as a shot of is a is
the URL for the publication that we find
here authored by Christie Sullivan Paul
Curtis and Lynn Bray ban on the IPM
staff Lynn will have a lot more to say
about this we'll probably do some
writing about this over the next couple
of weeks but suffice it to say right now
you know there are tricky there baits
and things and and we've got some
recommendations in these publications
but certainly one of the things that
they say loud and clear in here is that
insecticide use to kill insects that
prevent moles is not a viable strategy
so do not consider mold damage a license
for insecticide spray right now or an
insecticide application in fact we're
starting to secure this there is
evidence of course I didn't know this
until recently that moles consumed worms
right and for those of you with worm
problems there may be some relationship
in here that we may be exploring and
trying to understand moving forward so
Carl with that I want to adhere to our
idea of taking questions now so let me
let me get rid of them let me stop
sharing this screen and we can look at
the two of us and start to start to take
some questions how we doing on questions
let me have a sip of coffee yes so we
just got one question from Gary he's
asking specifically about well and
granular versus liquid control methods
and so I think that's a pretty specific
question but maybe a better way to look
at that question for the broader
audience here is many people probably
here in the lawn and landscape folks are
going to be using a granular
pre-emergent that also includes
fertilizer we talked with random process
yesterday about the granular methods of
pre-emergent control versus the liquids
what did he say in general so good
question okay so the rule of thumb is is
this the rule of thumb has always been
thus
about from a weed science perspective
and and thus is thus will never get as
good of control of NV weed in any way
with the granule application that
requires foliar update if it allows and
root uptake then then of course the
efficacy can be the same if not better
in some cases depending on the dynamics
of the root up cake hence hence the
reason the amino cyclope or the
umbrellas Fiasco a number of years ago
was so was so widespread because there
you had a broadleaf weed control product
post a merger probably pre control
product you could put on water in in it
and it gave you a route up thick which
is it was a good way to kill all those
trees about a bad way you know a good
way to kill the weeds goat would turn
out to be a good way to kill trees that
we we were very sorry that it happened
but I'm saying that's what it was used
for
that's why granular never works as well
as liquid now specifically about the
question with regard to so so you're
always going to get better post emergent
control when you spray Meza trial I
don't I'm trying to think it probably as
I understand it is a very effective
product for nimble will yeah and most of
the post emergent activity that I know
Massa try own has on annual bluegrass
and young crabgrass goose grass where
bleach is it when it's young you know
even please said you a little bit to a
certain extent you know you know my
sense is that it might it would do the
same thing to nimble well post emergent
in and that it would would require
foliar hitting it's not a root uptake it
kills those little plants foliar uptake
but it also has the ability to prevent
new establishment and Gary's question is
really really smart because it also
allows for overseas sososo Meza try own
is that one interesting product we have
on the market it's a it's an HP PD
of course chlorophylls synthesis
inhibiting herbicide pile acts to
promozone is in the same class of
materials they bleach the products they
bleed bleach the leaves of some plants
and cause death and that's what they do
to Nimba will I'm sure as well as Paula
and crabgrass a lot of grassy weeds but
at the same time oh sorry about that car
at the same time provides some
pre-emergent control now it's not the
best pre-emergent but because it gives
you the advantage of also doing some
seeding it works in conjunction with
that so long answer to a good short
question but I want to talk maybe you
know cry let me just say well I don't
see any questions and maybe you have a
something but but I didn't talk a lot
about seeding I should have and and what
I sure said is you know if you got a
picture like what's behind me in the
image you should be seated this isn't
really necessarily if you see the grass
behind me it looks well fertilized it
looks like it wants to grow but it's not
going to fill in quick enough and look
at how just narrow some of those spots
are right tell me how narrow some of
those spots are and still not going to
fill in there quickly that's a place to
chuck the seat that's the place to chuck
the seat and and again to get quick
cover I make sure I add some rye grass
in the mix come right now I'd say listen
just get the ground covered don't don't
worry about it and if you have a
bluegrass lawn and you want to throw
some rye grass in because Rossi said
throw rye grass in make sure it's a dark
blue green rye grass right because rye
grass is the better ones anywhere dark
blue green generally blend in better
with with good Kentucky bluegrass lawns
but now is the time to seed for these
bare areas and I like this over even
your pre-emergence at this time I'd like
to try seeding over even running out to
get the priests down but you know that's
a that's a that's a different way of
thinking about managing the landscape
yeah and I think it's also probably
easier to rationalize the seeding as an
essential practice again you know I
wouldn't be surprised a lot of people
listening to this are going to get
questions while they're out about it
doing work you know if you're spreading
anything is that essential if you're
putting any fertilizer down is that
essential the seeding I think in our
opinion is is something that it's more
essential reestablishing turf not even
come back with multiple herbicide
applications right you can just do the
seeding and again you know trying to
avoid the fertilizer applications to
push growth because that's just going to
require more work and more mowing the
seeding is probably a better option just
you can do it once you have the seat
down there right so let's just ask
ourselves for a second since there
really aren't any questions Carl we got
just a couple of minutes to record some
comments here at the end and we can
decide about editing them out later if
we want to but but but what makes a lawn
essential right I mean is a lawn
essential and I would say of course a
lawn is essential because we're going to
have an inch-and-a-half
rain storm this weekend in the
metropolitan New York area and through
much of the northeastern United States
you're gonna get an inch and a half of
rain in 36 hours that's at least the
storms that are pushing through the
Central Ohio Valley over the next couple
of days and as they do that they're
gonna dump an inch and a half of rain if
you got this picture behind me and you
got this bare soil everywhere guess
where that soils go
that's why lawns are essential at this
time because they're covering the ground
if people are saying what do you got to
go out and do I'm going out to make sure
the landscape can withstand the climate
and the rainfall that's coming but what
does that mean well I got to make sure
that lawn is dense and thick okay well
what do you need to do that well the
best thing to do right now is to throw
see because it's too early to feed it
and I don't want to stimulate growth
that if I can't get back out here I
can't manage because guess what it ain't
it's not a lawn if I don't mow it it's a
patch it's something else right so I'm
in the wrong business people are arguing
me about being in a golf business I
don't know it's not a golf course yeah
that's right so if you've got to argue
for the essential needs what are they
what makes it essential and it's a real
in my mind we've never had a better time
to demonstrate the value of the outdoors
in the natural world to our clientele
and helping them enjoy
means managing it to some degree it
doesn't manage itself
there's expertise involved there's
skilled labor I don't know a job I'd
call unskilled anymore you know that
whole idea skilled unskilled that's
gonna have a new meaning after something
like this this is hard work that we do
in a lawn and landscape business that
requires skill and precision I'm gonna
shut up it out so well I just wanted to
make one comment there Frank you know
again going to this you know raising
mowing Heights and having to mow less
the other thing that longer grass does
is it increases the time for the water
to get off the landscape so basically
it's it's retaining the water for a
longer period of time it's more
vegetation for the water to get through
and again it serves that essential
purpose of the lawn which is to control
water and let that implicate a little
bit and we've got a bunch of questions
and I'll 8tracks this question
mowing less is there any benefit to
letting the grass grow to seed so I
think there may be some variety species
considerations in there I would say but
I don't think there's any way to stop
that from happening
and I think this is a very good question
Travis because now I'm thinking uh
normally we have problems with stem eNOS
in lawns and a lot of times that's
because you know we let them grow a
little taller or they're a older variety
that was a good seed producer and you
get these stalks in the lawn we might
see more of that as we raise the height
of cut and then if we get into a dry
period we'll see them have that sort of
brown look to them so that is a concern
and it's something you should be
thinking about I don't know that there's
any benefit to it but there also if
we're gonna raise our Heights a cut and
have to cut back on our mowing frequency
I'm not sure there's any way to stop it
and just keep in mind the energy that
the plant is putting into that
reproductive organ it's not putting into
other aspects of its growth so to a
certain extent you might argue if we
can't mow for a while this might allow
for some finny
as well so so it's a very interesting
question Karl we're gonna have to come
back and just thinking about this Wow
letting the grass grow longer letting it
flower what are the implications gonna
be in some ways letting it grow taller
and letting it flower makes the plants
get bigger and the shoots per square
inch go down right instead you know it
doesn't get more dense it gets less
dense right but the roots go deeper if
they're able this is a very complex
question but I would start with what do
I got to do to minimize maintenance and
there's no question about it mowing
higher is gonna be the key but even some
I mean Yankee Stadium I'm a dad would
have problems sometimes even a two inch
high to cut with some rise and blues so
asking about we're gonna take concerns I
have Joe and layman you know arctic
expert I did get her on as a panelist
and Jo Ellen would you like to answer
this question increase our risk of
getting ticks in the law so this is an
excellent question it's something that
has come up a lot in every list of
recommendations that you see to reduce
ticks on your property is this idea to
mow the lawn short but there's
absolutely no research evidence to
support that and I can't find any of
these people that make that
recommendation to tell me what short
means so in my own personal research
that I did looking at whether mulching
leaves into lawns impacted tick
populations I can tell you that despite
height of cut the if it's sunny and dry
the ticks are just not going to be there
if you have areas that are high shade
and moist then the ticks are going to be
there so tick populations are going to
rely more on the micro
climate then on the height of cuts so at
this point I would say there is no
evidence that raising the mowing height
even to six inches is going to make a
difference in tech populations and tick
risk we get these questions and and and
I think we need more data and and and
JoEllen is is is working on the idea of
mulch mowing and its role with pick
populations and and right now we just
don't have good answers a lot of good
answers but the answers are I've always
liked what's hot right and you're saying
Joe Allen six inches isn't really hot
I don't believe that it is of course
it's higher than that before I mow it
down and I've seen no increase in tick
populations there I'm also in the middle
of a very sunny field so I don't have
time to populations anyway I want to do
one more question
Zebulon has a question about era
fication topdressing been seeding for
the next month what do you think about
going in and doing those practices
obviously that's going to take time of
Labor and he's looking specifically at
damaged areas okay so it looks like it's
a comparison between sort of prepping an
area for a seeding or prepping it then
sadi yes right and half that compared to
sodding it's Ozen if that's the question
you know in general if money is not an
option if money is not a factor I like
the quick cover of sod personally
especially at these times where you know
you have to rely on people to water it
but I want to step back for a second and
and and and and wonder about why we want
to aerate and put compost and then it
makes me think okay the first thing I
want to know is why did that area get
bin why did grass fail there once
already and then if before I decide
want to introduce compost essentially a
slow release nitrogen fertilizer i'm
only introducing that if I feel like the
soil structure itself the soil structure
itself needs help and if it hasn't been
able to sustain gratest on it for any
long period of time and there's plenty
of light there well then that might be
that the soil is in trouble and we know
this is popular in urban areas where
where the soil gets disturbed a lot or
it just has not been a lot able to
sustain plant growth for whatever reason
right or drains - well I don't know what
the physical issue is but I don't know
if compost is always the answer you know
I never asked a a turf manager an answer
to a bad turf problem with that didn't
include I never got an answer from a
turf manager about any problem they were
trying to fix that did not include
poking a hole in the ground I think we
think it's the solution for almost every
two golf course superintendents you
cannot date which if you tell them not
not to era fie so I don't know number
one if I need to air fight number two if
I need to put compost number three if I
need cedar side but if all else being
equal at this point I'd rather see the
ground covered with the rain coming that
we know is coming the only problem with
siding is it limits the varieties that
you could get so so so if you think you
want to go tall fescue but you can't get
tall fescue sod or you think you want to
go blue grass but you can't get the
right varieties you like that's a that's
a different question so that's again
another long answer cause I gotta I
gotta know I think and I think what
we'll wrap up today on is the growth
regulator question Gary's got a couple
questions about weed control and maybe
next week we'll focus a little bit more
intently on weed control but - so poetry
V Alice and then Gary also mentioned
Kyle Inga down here with estriol on
granular sulphate tri-zone first off
poetry V Alice right rough stock
bluegrass has become a huge issue in in
the lawn care and in throughout northern
climes
some of it is is related to
it's contaminated see no one no one
likes to say it but for many many years
that was a number one grass sold in the
United States and it was primarily sold
to the market in the south that were
over seeding golf courses for three
months and then you know killing it and
and the reason that it was a great grass
is it did beautiful in the spring Oh
poet reveals menu you think wow that
poetry Alice ever and then the summer
comes and that was good if you were in
the south because then it all died well
now we get stuck having to manage it
it's clumpy it's yellow it doesn't
respond at all well to irrigation it
doesn't play nice sometimes and it's
established itself the only really
effective control I've seen that's
reliable is a product we can no longer
use called certainty I believe it was a
sulfonylurea that you used in certainty
and that is no longer available for use
in cool-season turf now now I believe a
claim of phenoxy prop has poet ruby
Alice on the label and can be effective
and I would encourage you to consider
maybe using a methylated seed oil as
well to enhance uptake like you get with
a lot of these what we used to call the
flop tops and dims right that class of
herbicides that binocs of properties in
so so that's a good option you know and
this MA used to be good we don't have MS
MA anymore and I gotta say let me let me
leave poetry there for a second Gary and
talk about Chi Linga I don't really know
a lot about kailia I'm learning more
about Chi Linga and let me encourage you
Carl we'll put a link up there for Gary
bolt on poetry and false green KY Linga
not Elmore at Rutgers our weed science
colleague at Rutgers University and of
course our shortcut colleague Randy
prospect I you mash as well have talked
a lot about how these weeds are emerging
as bigger problems right as the climates
been changing so so I refer you to
Matt's publication for what we think are
viable strategies he studied this as
best as anybody will definitely have
some more discussion about this as Carl
said about weed control moving forward
but for now I refer you to Matt Elmore's
work he's been doing this the most down
at Rutgers ok Carl what's this last
question just a last question about the
growth regulators and if that's gonna
reduce cut frequency and we talked about
this really in depth yesterday in the
sports one I'm probably the most in
depth in the golf conversation but maybe
you could just give a kind of surface
level idea of how those could be useful
and particularly useful spring/summer
yeah ok so so there's a couple of things
to consider plant growth regulator use
I've been in you know Carl is when I
feel like I've been around his business
entirely too long I remember in the
early 1990s when primo was developed as
a foliar the you know a foliar growth
regulator it was one of those well you
know you had cutlass and trim it pack of
groups was all a floor criminal back at
the back in the day and they were all
soil observing with soil absorbed and
then the foliar came along and it looked
like you could regulate growth without
loss and turf quality but here you know
that fundamentally remains the problem
with growth regulation and in lawn
environment is that in general of all
the three disciplines even golf right
now where people are willing to put up
with a little bit of injury you're
you're saying you know you I would tell
you that the first thing you have to
consider in lawn conditions is that your
likelihood of some injury is greater for
one reason in general when you mow
higher the grass grows slower the grass
grow slower when you don't because
theoretically as we've just said if you
mow it higher you mow it less frequently
because you could let it go higher and
still observe the 1/3 rule the reason to
observe the 1/3 rule is that that
suppresses growth the most so if you're
in the lawn business and you're looking
to say your essential well I gotta keep
up with the 1/3 rule which means I got
to get out there and mow at this time
otherwise the grass grows too much so
growth rate is tied to mowing height
mowing height and drives mowing
frequency and those things drive growth
with
you're trying to suppress so roads
regulation in the lawn environments
going to be tricky without some effect
on quality however I think by next week
when we do this again I'm going to have
a better understanding of applying
growth regulators to the turf because we
may be closer to when they could do you
something and we want to give you some
good recommendations because these
things can be used on lawns they've just
no been never been any interest because
number one people get paid to mow
people like them all in fact Scots came
to the market with a PGR many years ago
for the homeowner and it was one of
their worst performing products in the
history of Scots because the people who
used it really like cutting their grass
and we're sort of pissed they couldn't
cut it any more and then the people that
put it on crappy lawns their lawns look
worse so it's a very funny thing if you
have a lot of weeds you're not going to
get regulation of the same degree of
different plants you get nutsedge
doesn't regulate like rye grass rye
grass doesn't regulate like blue grass
blue grass doesn't regulate like fine
fescue yeah it's a complicated question
in the lawn to use growth regulator so I
would wait until we can get some better
information out there about what are
going to be the consequences of this
yeah and then I think we can finish up
with one last quick ending question
Kathy's asking about should we put down
grass seed in the Rochester area well
okay so let's think of reasons not the
big reason not is if you get our inch
and a half of rain it's my Washington
that's that's a reason not right now but
but if you put it down and mulch it
that's been then I've mitigated that
problem so the general concern we'll
wait the soil is really cool I'm like
yeah perfect this is called dormancy
that there's some evidence that Riker
did this work many years ago at Purdue
University that showed seeding bluegrass
earlier in the season or under dormant
conditions tends to lead to a more
bluegrass dominated stand in that first
year second year period right now after
that it becomes how you manage it but
early on there is a value to getting the
seed down this early now I tell you
you're gonna get seed loss you're going
to get some seed loss at
time no matter what whether it's washing
away or you know it stays cold or you
know you're gonna expect someone so I
would think I'll put twenty thirty
percent more seed down and then you know
we're making a recommendation for four
pounds maybe put five and a half you
know something like that or six right
just go thirty twenty thirty percent
more that could be a good way to do it
and and and something that you can
justify as well I think you're going to
see the benefits of it particularly over
if you're battling that versus
pre-emergent chemicals I'd rather see
you take this at least to start now
especially Rochester yeah yeah so um
yeah we got a lot of questions today
about forty five minutes so I think a
what we'll do is wrap it up here and and
I think the plan as of now is to do this
again next week we got you know 42 or 43
at our max today participants again as a
recording on YouTube next week same time
same link I hope to see everybody in
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu